hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live mit einem update zur aktuellen
situation in afghanistan
nachdem es dort zwei explosionen gab und
mehrere tote und verletzte
in wenigen minuten ja tatsächlich ich
schaue jetzt kurz danach in wenigen
minuten soll der bundesaußenminister
heiko maas zudem sprechen und wir geben
jetzt auch ab nach berlin wurde er
außenminister spricht
angehörige verloren haben oder jetzt
noch um 7
wir haben zurzeit keine informationen
über deutsche opfer
dieser anschlag zeigt unter welchen
dramatischen und gefährlichen
bedingungen
und so bundeswehrsoldaten und das
kernteam unserer botschaft in den
vergangenen elf tagen gearbeitet
und was sie unglaubliches geleistet
haben gesagt ihnen dafür zutiefst
dankbar
gemeinsam mit vielen weiteren
kolleginnen und kollegen in berlin und
taschkent haben sie es geschafft mehr
als 5300 menschen aus kabul aufzufliegen
und sicher nach deutschland zu bringen
darunter waren mehr als für von der
deutsche
über 4000 menschen aus afghanistan
die hälfte davon frauen
aber das war nur möglich dank engster
zusammenarbeit mit unseren partnern wir
haben hunderte menschen aus 43 nationen
ausgeflogen und gleichzeitig haben wir
selbst unsere staatsangehörigen auf
evakuierungsflüge unserer partner in
sicherheit bringen können die
militärische evakuierung ist nun beendet
aber unsere arbeit geht weiter und zwar
so lange bis alle in sicherheit sind für
die wir in haft eine verantwortung
tragen
deshalb geht unsere hilfsaktion heute in
eine neue phase
und zwar von beginn an gewusst dass das
fenster für die luftbrücke nur für eine
begrenzte zeit offen stehen wird
daher haben wir parallel zu den
evakuierungen schon für die zeit danach
geplant
mit den in afghanistan verbliebenen
deutschen staatsangehörigen stehen wir
weiter in direktem kontakt wie werden
sie fortlaufend informieren wie es uns
möglich ist sie mit einer organisierten
ausweise zu unterstützen dazu führen wir
gespräche mit verschiedenen partnern und
ja auch mit den taliban zb über den
weiterer tipp des flughafens damit in
zukunft auch wieder zivile flüge möglich
sein werden
ein weiterer weg führt über den
nachbarstaaten afghanistans
werden mit unseren botschaften an der
grenze ab der grenze dafür konsularische
unterstützung leisten aber wir werden
auch alles daran setzen den ort kräften
die jetzt noch in afghanistan sind die
ausreise zu ermöglichen
das gilt für die gesamte bundesregierung
unsere botschaften in den nachbarstaaten
haben seit gestern die anweisung ein
einreisepapiere an alle ortskräfte zu
erteilen die bereits eine aufnahme
zusage erhalten haben dafür werden wir
diese botschaften personell unverzüglich
verstärken
auch alle anderen
können weiter ihren früheren
arbeitgebern eine gefährdung sun zahl
gestellt
auch für diejenigen afghaninnen und
afghanen etwa aus der zivilgesellschaft
medien und wissenschaft die die
bundesregierung bis zum ende der
militärischen evakuierungsaktion schon
als besonders gefährdet identifiziert
hat und denen wir eine ausreise mit der
bundeswehr in aussicht gestellt haben
auch für diese schaffen wir eine
ausweise perspektive sie werden von uns
eine aufnahme zu sagen mit der sie bei
unseren botschaften der nachbarstaaten
schnell und unkompliziert visa für
deutschland erhalten können
sind dabei
absprache mit den nachbarn länder um die
es geht zu treffen damit afghaninnen und
afghanen von der grenze schnell und
sicher zu unseren botschaften gelangen
können
dafür reiche ich am sonntag zu einer
reise in die region auf um darüber mit
den kollegen im fertig ist der usbeke
und pakistan zu sprechen wir haben
umgekehrt auch deutlich gemacht dass wir
bereit sind die nachbarstaaten dabei zu
unterstützen die humanitären folgen der
erschütterungen in afghanistan zu
bewältigen
auf meiner reise wird es auch darum
gehen wie wir als internationale
gemeinschaft mit den neuen realitäten in
afghanistan umgehen unter welchen
bedingungen wir mit einer neuen
regierung absprachen zu treffen bereit
sind deshalb werde ich auch die türkei
und katar besuchen die in dieser frage
eine wichtige rolle spielen für uns
bleibt der maßstab derselbe die
einhaltung von grundlegenden menschen-
und frauenrechte und die gewähr dass
unsere hilfen allen menschen zugute
kommen diese auch nötig an
deshalb haben wir den vereinten nationen
100 millionen euro zur verfügung
gestellt um notleidenden menschen vor
ort direkt hilfe leisten zu können
weitere 500 millionen euro für
notleidende menschen in afghanistan und
auch der region vielen dank
damals das war das statement von
bundesaußenminister heiko maas zur
aktuellen lage in afghanistan darüber
wollen wir nun sprechen ob das ganze ein
ordner mit unserer hauptstadt
korrespondentin in berlin stelle
banerjee hallo guten abend hallo
der bundesaußenminister hat sich gerade
geäußert zu der situation sowohl in
afghanistan aber auch zu den weiteren
plänen wie es jetzt weitergeht denn eins
ist klar die evakuierungs mission ist
jetzt damit zumindest die militärische
beendet was hat er in aussicht gestellt
wie es jetzt weitergehen soll für die
menschen die sich noch vor ort in
afghanistan befinden also er ist auf der
linie geblieben die die bundesregierung
heute schon den ganzen tag skizziert hat
sie will sehr deutlich machen habe ich
den eindruck dass der wille weiterhin
besteht so vielen menschen wie möglich
dabei zu helfen aus afghanistan
auszureisen vor allem denjenigen denen
man schon eine ausreise zusage gemacht
hat das dürften vor allem ortskräfte
sein die für deutschland gearbeitet
haben aber heiko maas hat es gerade auch
noch einmal betont auch solche menschen
die besonders gefährdet sind darüber ist
ja in den vergangenen tagen öfter schon
diskutiert worden also menschen die sich
für frauenrechte für menschenrechte
eingesetzt haben die besonders exponiert
waren und sich in feldern betätigt haben
die jetzt von den taliban besonders
kritisch gesehen werden und wo die diese
menschen jetzt eben angst haben dass sie
mit repressalien
zu rechnen haben oder sogar um ihr leben
fürchten müssen diese sollen alle
ausreisen können dafür werden die
botschaften deutschen botschaften in den
nachbarländern personell verstärkt damit
die verstärkt auch ausreisepapiere
ausstellen können man setzt da ganz
offensichtlich darauf dass es nach der
beendigung der luftbrücke die er heute
die heute so verkündet worden ist dieses
ende ist heute so verkündet worden noch
mit zivilen flügen weiterhelfen kann
menschen auszufliegen oder aber auch
menschen auf dem landweg in die
nachbarländer zu bringen die große frage
ist kann das überhaupt noch gelingen
sowohl die verteidigungsministerin die
sich zuvor geäußert hat als auch jetzt
der außenminister sprachen also davon
dass quasi diese zusagen die aufnahme
zusagen gemacht worden sind auch
bestehen bleiben sollen die große frage
ist jetzt natürlich wie sollen männer
also überhaupt das land verlassen wenn
jetzt diese militärische aktion am
flughafen beendet es der außenminister
sprach davon in die region zu reisen und
eben auch mit verschiedensten partnern
zu verhandeln was hat er dazu genau
gesagt und auch zu den
verhandlungsoptionen mit den taliban er
hat seine reise für sonntag angekündigt
in die nachbarländer vor allem die
nördliche region nach tadschikistan
usbekistan und dann auch noch rüber nach
pakistan an der pakistanischen grenze
stehen ja schon viele viele menschen die
versuchen rüber zu kommen da gibt es
auch schon bilder von grenzübergängen an
denen man sieht wie sich die menschen
dort drängen und zum teil nicht
reingelassen werden da soll es jetzt
also verhandlungen darüber geben wie man
diese länder unterstützen kann das sind
ja alles länder mit denen man auch in
der vergangenheit nicht immer unbedingt
reibungslos zusammengearbeitet hat die
wir auch nicht unbedingt als lupenreine
demokratie
bezeichnen würden sondern die selber
einige probleme haben und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so ohne weiteres dazu bereit
sein werden zigtausende menschen aus
afghanistan aufzunehmen heiko maas hat
angedeutet dass es da eben hilfen und
unterstützungen geben kann er hat schon
gesagt die vereinten nationen haben
bereits geld bekommen jetzt muss ich mal
auf den zettel gucken das war 100
millionen euro die für die vereinten
nationen zur verfügung gestellt worden
sind und weitere 500 millionen euro für
menschen die in afghanistan vertrieben
worden sind das ist alles noch relativ
vage das beschreibt worum sich die
bundesregierung jetzt bemüht es macht
noch keine aussage darüber ob das
tatsächlich den menschen dabei hilft die
aus afghanistan raus wollen denn wir
haben ja heute auch gesehen an den
fürchterlichen anschlägen am kabuler
flughafen dass nicht nur die taliban mit
denen die bundesregierung jetzt gerade
verhandelt in afghanistan versuchen die
lage zu bestimmen sondern dass auch
andere kräfte dort noch unterwegs sind
das war heute die rede davon dass der
dass die anschläge vom sogenannten
islamischen staates der terror
organisation ausgeführt worden sind auch
al qaida scheint in der region noch eine
rolle zu spielen und das sind jetzt eben
kräfte die zum teil auch gegeneinander
arbeiten also während die
bundesregierung mit den taliban und
weiteren partnern wie es heiko maas eben
gesagt hat verhandelt tut sich im land
noch relativ viel und es wird sich in
den nächsten tagen und wochen zeigen
müssen wie sicher die zusagen sind die
die taliban der bundesregierung auch
geben können
auch bundeskanzlerin merkel hat sich
heute dazu geäußert zur aktuellen
situation in afghanistan
und da wollen wir jetzt kurz gemeinsam
reinhören wir kennen noch nicht alle
einzelheiten aber die terroristen nahmen
auf menschen gezielt die vor den
flughafen toren gewartet haben und auf
ihre ausreise hoffen sie wollen
sicherheit und freiheit für sich und
deshalb ist dies ein absolut
niederträchtiger anschlag in der nacht
sehr sehr angespannten situationen und
ich denke in diesen minuten natürlich an
die opfer und ihre angehörigen
zum schluss noch die frage der
bundesaußenminister hat sich auch zu den
orts kräften vor ort um die es in den
letzten tagen ja immer wieder ging hat
sich auch zu denen geäußert denn da
sitzen ja auch nach wie vor noch viele
menschen fest die zuvor mit deutschland
zusammengearbeitet haben was hat er dazu
gesagt und wie ist das einzuschätzen
also auch heiko maas sagt ganz klar wir
sind diesen menschen verpflichtet ist
ist das haben heute auch annegret kramp
karrenbauer die verteidigungsministerin
und angela merkel klar gemacht man
versucht geben allen denen man eine
zusage zur ausreise gegeben hat sie noch
rauszubekommen heiko maas hat auch
gesagt das zeitfenster um diese menschen
mit der luftbrücke rauszuholen das war
sehr kurz das habe man vorher schon
gewusst jetzt drehte man in eine neue
phase ein die man eben schon vorher
vorbereitet hat gemeint ist damit
offensichtlich dass man vorher schon
verhandelt hat aber diese verhandlungen
sind eben nicht zu ende über die frage
wie bekommt man diese menschen
tatsächlich organisiert und sicher aus
dem land heraus wo sollen sie dann hin
und da haben sich heute übrigens auch
schon mehrere bundesländer die von
verschiedenen parteien regiert werden
also parteiübergreifend an die
bundesregierung gewandt und haben gesagt
wir brauchen gespräche auch hier in
deutschland darüber wie wir denjenigen
die wir zurücklassen mussten in
afghanistan helfen können und wie wir
ihnen auch hier in deutschland helfen
können das ist die bereitschaft dort
denjenigen denen man versprechen gemacht
hat für ihre sicherheit auch tatsächlich
zu helfen die scheint sehr groß zu sein
aber der weg dahin der ist heute erst
einmal unklarer ist so vor vielen dank
für diese analyse heute abend nach
berlin konnte ben ali danke
und wir schauen jetzt noch einmal in
einem beitrag auf die aktuelle situation
in afghanistan in kabul und was heute
dort genau geschehen ist ein bericht von
blick war bot
ein erster sprengsatz explodierte
unmittelbar neben einem von us soldaten
bewachten tor kurz danach eine weitere
explosion in einem hotel in
flughafennähe das als sammelpunkt für
ausreichend bedient mindestens zwölf
menschen kamen ums leben krankenhäuser
berichten von dutzenden verletzten die
explosion war da im wassergraben in dem
die leute stand wir sind sofort aus dem
graben raus aber da lagen ganz viele
menschen blut ich auf dem boden zum teil
auch zerfetzte körper alle haben
geschrien das war eine sehr heftige
explosion auch ausländische soldaten
waren betroffen
nach amerikanischen medienberichten sind
terroristen einer splittergruppe des des
sogenannten islamischen staates für die
anschläge verantwortlich geheimdienste
hatten in den letzten tagen wiederholt
vor einem hohen risiko gewarnt der
sprecher des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministeriums bestätigte
dass auch us-soldaten bei den anschlägen
verletzt wurden bundeswehr-soldaten so
hieß es in berlin seien nicht betroffen
den ganzen tag über starteten weiter
maschinen aus kabul es sind wohl mit die
letzten zivilisten die heute noch über
die militärische luftbrücke die ausreise
geschafft haben zahlreiche staaten wie
kanada belgien und ungarn haben die
evakuierungsflüge inzwischen eingestellt
die amerikaner und ihre verbündeten
haben bereits mit dem abtransport von
mannschaften und material begonnen der
bis zum nächsten dienstag abgeschlossen
sein soll schutzbedürftige könnten dann
mit zivilen flugzeugen ausgeflogen
werden heißt es ein zeitpunkt ab wann
das möglich sein wird ist nicht bekannt
wir sprechen nun mit elmar theveßen
unserem usa korrespondent in washington
guten abend emma wir können und wir
haben gerade im beitrag gehört dass auch
die us-truppen also vor ort an ihrem
zeitplan festhalten wollen und also bis
zum dienstag diesen evakuierungen
evakuierungseinsatz beendet haben wollen
dazu gibt es auch keine neuen
erkenntnisse dabei bleibt ist
nach jetzigem stand ja aber wir erwarten
natürlich darauf dass der us-präsident
sich heute noch äußern wird das villa
wohl ganz offenbar denn nach neuesten
informationen aus dem pentagon sind ganz
offenbar mehrere us-soldaten auch bei
diesen anschlägen getötet worden wir
hören dass es drei marines mindestens
gewesen sein sollen die gestorben sind
heute bei diesen doppelanschlägen gehen
kabul das was man gesehen hat in den
videos von vor ort wir haben tat auch
videos unmittelbar nach den explosionen
bekommen mittlerweile da kann man schon
sehen dass dieses ziel einerseits wohl
ganz gezielt ausgewählt worden ist
dieses bern hotel liegt in unmittelbarer
nähe dieses gates dieses tors
normalerweise werden von diesem hotel
aus eben menschen allen voran
staatsbürger verschiedener länder aber
auch afghanen die den usa unter anderem
geholfen haben direkt eskortiert
teilweise auch von soldaten eskortiert
eben zu diesem eingangsbereich vom
flughafen die straße ist er eng auf der
einen seite ist eine mauer auf der
anderen seite der graben von dem wir vor
in dem beitrag auch gehört haben in dem
graben saßen in den letzten tagen
hunderte tausende von menschen und haben
gewartet ob sie nicht auch zugang zum
flughafen bekommen können also dieses
ziel wurde so ausgewählt dass man ich
sage es mal so größtmöglichen schaden
anrichtet zum zweiten aber auch wirft
dass einige fragen auf hieß es den
attentätern gelungen bis dorthin zu
kommen denn im umfeld gibt es mehrere
checkpoints der taliban das umfeld wird
auch unmittelbar sehr intensiv überwacht
durch die amerikanischen aber auch
andere streitkräfte eben weil es so ein
sensibler bereich ist es gibt noch eine
menge fragen die offen sind und darunter
gehört dazu gehört eben auch die frage
ob die evakuierungen so weiterlaufen wie
geplant bis zum nächsten dienstag oder
mittwoch du sagst dass viele offene
fragen da natürlich auch die frage ist
dann schon mehr klar wer dafür
verantwortlich ist auch das pentagon der
pentagon-sprecher hat sich heute
geäußert es dazu irgendetwas bekannt
also es gibt noch keine konkreten
hinweise oder belege dafür dass der
islamische staat curasan so wie er sich
nennt das ist ein ableger des in
afghanistan eben dass dieser dafür
verantwortlich sei es sieht alles nach
einer koordinierten attacken aus weil
sie synchronisiert war möglicherweise
auch flankiert wurde von bewaffneten
kräften die versucht haben den weg dann
auch frei zu schießen für die attentäter
das ist noch nicht endgültig bestätigt
aber das ist sagen wir mal die
naheliegendste vermutungen dass es sich
um den islamischen staat curasan handelt
der hinter dieser attacke steckt denn er
gilt als geschworener feind der taliban
wird alles tun um den usa aber auch den
taliban zu schaden das sind wirklich
konkurrieren miteinander verfeindeten
gruppierungen
aber es ist nicht auszuschließen dass
andere gruppen dahinter stecken es gibt
eine vielzahl von terrorgruppen in
afghanistan darunter natürlich auch al
qaida al kaida hat etwa 4 bis 6 100
kämpfer in afghanistan zur zeit aber das
ist die einschränkung al kaida wird
gesehen derzeit als enger verbündeter
der taliban ist integriert teilweise in
die struktur der taliban insofern
unwahrscheinlich dass al kaida dahinter
steckt der wahrscheinlichste verdächtige
ist eben ihre ska und wir hoffen uns vom
präsidenten und natürlich auch vom
pentagon in den nächsten stunden nähere
hinweise darauf ganz offenbar gab es ja
in den letzten tagen sehr konkrete
warnungen vor solch einer attacke also
möglicherweise auch
geheimdienstinformationen die schon sehr
in richtung islamischer staat kores
angedeutet haben die usa behaupteten
zuvor steht sie hätten terrorgefahr auch
aus der ferne im griff was bedeutet das
genau jetzt auch gerade für so eine
situation
ja ich glaube man sollte sich nicht
selber täuschen die terrorgefahr war in
den vergangenen jahren auch in
afghanistan extrem hoch egal ob nun
zweieinhalb tausend us-soldaten und
alliierte streitkräfte dort standen wie
in jüngster zeit oder vielleicht viele
tausend mehr es hat immer wieder
anschläge gegeben irgendwo im land auch
in afghanistan in kabul in der
hauptstadt hat es anschläge gegeben ich
erinnere daran unmittelbar auf den
bereich in dem eben auch die
amerikanische botschaft lag also
anschläge wurden folgt in der
vergangenheit und das kann das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen natürlich auch in
den nächsten tagen passieren das kann
die evakuierung natürlich weiter
beeinträchtigen und natürlich weiß auch
jeder dass startende flugzeuge in großer
gefahr sind von raketen getroffen zu
werden wenn sie abgefeuert werden
insofern ist es extrem wichtig dass
einerseits die taliban wenn sie wollen
dass die evakuierung am 31 zu ende geht
massiv dazu beitragen dass die
sicherheit wiederhergestellt wird am und
um den flughafen andererseits aber
natürlich auch die westlichen kräfte
allen voran die usa ihre
aufklärungskapazitäten nutzen alles was
sie an informationen bekommen können um
diesen bereich rund um den flughafen zu
sichern bevor wir weiter dann auch in
die analyse gehen und auch noch weiter
über die ereignisse des tages sprechen
heute hat sich auch die deutsche
verteidigungsministerium geäußert und
von ihr haben wir auch ein statement
vorliegen und wollen da jetzt noch mal
kurz reinhören dies ist ein feiger und
dies waren feige terroristische
attentate die wir alle auf das tiefste
verurteilen unsere gedanken meine
gedanken sind jetzt bei den opfern
dieses anschlages bei den getöteten bei
den verwundeten
egal ob es sich um die zivilisten vor
dem tor handelt oder die soldatinnen und
soldaten die im einsatz dort verletzt
worden sind deutsche soldaten und
soldatinnen wurden bei diesen anschlägen
nicht verletzt zur identität der opfer
liegen uns bisher keine informationen
vor
deutsche soldaten wurden nicht verletzt
haben wir da gehört immer du hast du
zuvor angesprochen auf amerikanischer
seite hingegen gibt es meldungen darüber
ist das richtig
ja das pentagon hat bestätigt dass eben
mehrere us-soldaten auch getötet worden
sind bei diesen doppelanschlägen die
genaue zahl ist bisher nicht bekannt
gegeben das wird wahrscheinlich gleich
in einem briefing des pentagon dann noch
erfolgen aber wir hören aus anderen
quellen dass es mindestens drei us
marines sind deren aufgabe war eben
evakuierte in den flughafen hinein zu
bringen die bei diesem anschlag getötet
worden sind also dieser weg dieser zu
weg ist tatsächlich eine über den
menschen eskortiert worden sind von
us-soldaten auch von anderen soldaten
auch von britischen fallschirmjägern
beispielsweise insofern ist das ein ich
sag mal taktisch sehr wichtiges ziel und
ein sehr
gefährdet das ziel gewesen gerade in den
letzten wochen und monaten ich glaube
was der terrorgefahr massiv beigetragen
hat das muss man auch noch einmal sagen
die taliban haben auf ihrem siegeszug ja
in allen landesteilen auch in kabul
selber die gefängnisse geöffnet in
diesen gefängnissen sitzen terroristen
sowohl des islamischen staates curasan
als auch al kaida und anderer
gruppierungen mit anderen worten die
taliban haben erheblich dazu beigetragen
dass die terrorgefahr sich in kabul und
gerade auch am flughafen erhöht hat das
rächt sich jetzt und es rächt sich auch
für die amerikaner dass sie das flugfeld
wagram aufgegeben haben das war ein
flughafen in der nähe von kabul der
eigentlich sehr abgelegen liegt der viel
besser zu schützen wäre als ebenso ein
ziviler flughafen auch das rächt sich
jetzt man hätte möglicherweise diese
ganze evakuierungsaktion ein stück weit
sicherer durchführen können als am
flughafen von kabul
du hast das angesprochen also auch die
usa nicht nur die usa aber unter anderem
haben also zuvor davor gewarnt dass es
tatsächlich auch zu einer situation vor
dem flughafen also zu einer gefährlichen
situation möglicherweise ein anschlag
vor dem flughafen kommen kann wieso ist
denn da tatsächlich so ein chaos
entstanden und wurde dann jetzt auch
selbst mit dieser warnung nicht
aufgelöst sind dazu wenige truppen vor
ort gewesen
ja man kann es drehen und wenden wie man
will 5600 us soldaten sind am flughafen
sind auch am flughafen
auch soldaten anderer länder das reicht
natürlich um den flughafen selber
unmittelbar zu schützen aber nicht das
gesamte umfeld unter war man das kann
man beklagen oder nicht aber eben auf
einen deal mit den taliban angewiesen
dass die taliban die ein großes
interesse daran haben dass am 31 august
tatsächlich auch die evakuierung beendet
wird das die taliban dazu beitragen
sicherheit rund um den flughafen zu
gewährleisten diese konzentration auf
den flughafen hat sicher auch dazu
geführt dass kräfte der usa die vorher
in der lage gewesen waren auch
informationen zu sammeln mit informanten
zu reden beispielsweise in der stadt den
carbo selber dass diese kräfte eben alle
sehr konzentriert waren auf den
flughafen so dass es auch an
informationen fehlte es gab trotzdem das
wissen wir konkrete hinweise in den
letzten tagen auf mögliche anschläge am
flughafen deswegen sind ja amerikanische
staatsbürger auf die staatsbürger
anderer länder auch deren helfer
afghanen die in den vergangenen jahren
den streitkräften hilfreich gewesen sind
die sind gewarnt worden sie sollten auf
keinen fall zum flughafen kommen sondern
sollten sich melden über andere wege und
kanäle damit man dann einen möglichst
sicheren weg in den flughafen bereich
findet man das hat das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen jetzt vor allen
dingen die menschen getroffen die trotz
der warnungen am flughafen selber
ausgedacht haben im grunde genommen die
die am wenigsten hoffnung hatten die am
meisten angst hatten die doch die eben
gerade in dieser straße in diesem kanal
der in der tat überfüllt war mit
menschen in den letzten tagen ausgeharrt
haben um irgendwie noch eine chance zu
haben afghanistan zu verlassen die hat
es in erster linie getroffen in diesem
gerade in einer eil eil meldung dass der
un generalsekretär die veto mächte zu
einer krisensitzung einlädt also auch
die usa was kann denn ein solches
treffen bringen tatsächlich die usa ja
ziemlich deutlich gemacht auch dass sie
nicht länger bleiben wollen
ja der generalsekretär wenn ich das
richtig gesehen habe lädt ein zu
gesprächen am kommenden montag mit
diesen mächten es geht dabei nicht um
die unmittelbare situation glaube ich am
flughafen von kabul da konzentriert man
alle kräfte jetzt natürlich darauf so
viele menschen wie möglich noch in den
nächsten tagen so sicher wie möglich
auch heraus zu bekommen aber der 31
august steht ich glaube auch dass sich
das nicht verändern wird aber die
vereinten nationen und andere werden
beraten und müssen beraten ob es andere
wege geben soll in den nächsten tagen
und wochen dass man menschen die
afghanistan verlassen wollen auch ihnen
die gelegenheit dazu gibt dass sie
beispielsweise auf dem landwege in
andere länder in umliegende länder
reisen können fahren können wie auch
immer sie dahin kommen und von dort von
flughäfen dort eben evakuiert werden
können da ist es sehr wichtig dass
staaten wie pakistan indien ein
stückweit iran aber auch russland und
die ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
an solchen verhandlungen beteiligt sind
um menschen so etwas zu ermöglichen die
taliban selber haben in einem interview
mit unseren kollegen von nbc ja
signalisiert dass sie bereit wären
menschen die afghanistan verlassen
wollen auch dieses zu ermöglichen auch
wenn sie gleichzeitig sagen sie brauchen
menschen die das land wieder mit
aufbauen sie brauchen ingenieure sie
brauchen die ausgebildete kräfte und
haben allen anlass die versprochen was
immer sie in den letzten jahren getan
haben ob man den versprechen trauen
schenken darf ist das eine aber vor
allen dingen ob die menschen diesen
versprechen trauen das ist das andere
und ich glaube sehr viele werden auch in
den kommenden wochen versuchen das land
zu verlassen und das wird natürlich die
flüchtlingsströme wieder auslösen in
richtung beispielsweise pakistan und da
kommt es ja darauf an dass diese
nachbarstaaten möglicherweise über die
vereinten nationen auch die hilfe für
diese flüchtlinge koordinieren vielen
dank für die einschätzung heute abend el
mati wissen in washington danke
und an dieser stelle auch danke an euch
für eure aufmerksamkeit danke dass ihr
zugeschaut habt und wir behalten die
lage vor ort natürlich weiter im blick
bis dahin tschüss